oh you picked a good night huh your
pictures are good now
yeah oh yeah oh what's this what is this
i believe is that your own tequila
tequila then i'm happy
is that that's good before we start
i had last year castmates bill murray
matt damon and hugh bongo come on the
show yes
and they left the premiere i left them
drunk
and they got here and they got drunker
and i've never seen a television show
like that in my life
we've never had one like that before
because they got they arrived and they
got drunk or drunk
by the end it was like i'm really glad
the show's over now
they were throwing fruit at the edge
bill murray threw a whole pineapple into
the audience
it could have ended badly that's like a
challenge
now so yeah you're very welcome all of
you and it's like george's gonna use i
feel like the party can start
the party can start talking he's here
yeah and thank you for using my whole
name
because i usually you know i like george
clooney
a couple of nephews who are like seven
years old who i've now married into and
they come up to me and they go hey
george clooney
not uncle george i'm george clooney i'm
with them george seems over familiar
i'm just george sir george
because everyone who works with you they
always say you make work fun
is that i didn't say that
yes you yeah you said actually it sounds
kind of annoying you said people
whistled on their way to work when
george was on set
well i whistled i was so happy yeah no
he does he's he's uh he's the man said
no
come on let me just say we had a lot of
uh doctor talk
between us i did there was a lot of i
didn't understand any of it but we
didn't have it
i was surprised you didn't remember he
didn't remember any of it
no he remembers whole reams of stuff
which
from considerably longer ago and i i
cannot remember any of it
i could remember it 10 minutes after
i've said it so the gobbledygook about
half a stat and
you know all that what was that really
long word that you would say
superventricular tachyrhythmia yeah
that's good
now i'll tell you this when we shot that
scene
i did not get that word right
[Music]
but i've never gotten it wrong since it
was a horrifying experience
but i do yeah i think that how long did
you do the show
yes eight years and you don't remember
any of it
i tell you the one thing i have carried
over from then is when
when i do play another role now and a
director says action
i start limping
nobody noticed no they they don't care
they don't care
and uh brit if you had to choose i mean
i don't wish you ill
but if something bad did happen if you
were feeling don't make her choose
between the doctors yeah who would you
go to would you go to dr house there
well it depends on the illness because
you were great with like specialty
issues right you would always find you
would figure out
yeah it was pigeon poo from africa or
something what was it yeah i don't
remember
if
you know this now i think if i think
because you would always look
uh you would look past the obvious
choice the obvious diagnosis so
i don't know he might have a one-up on
you well he does because i was a
pediatrician so you're too old
yeah you're right yeah you're just a
pass i don't care
yeah that's the right choice for me yeah
yeah yeah
just keep pushing that gurney she's not
stopping here
because
[Music]
you